what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today join with
me of course co-host John Humphrey John
Humphrey how are you how was your
Christmas did you have a good Christmas
it was a pretty good mostly a pretty
good Christmas mostly a pretty good
Christmas I dressed up and I stole
presents from John's household yeah yeah
and then when I realized you know like a
couple hours in that this was a grinch
role play then I had a lot more fun with
it you're not getting the presents yet
yeah I there's still some trauma and
that's part of it when I showed up at my
place
and then he burned them all in front of
me you know who's burning stuff James
Gunn he's Bernie the DC Universe
boycott w beat difference still in
recovery mode guys okay you might hear
it in my voice a little bit Zachary Levi
and James Gunn versus DC fans that's
what I'm gonna say for this video I'm
gonna set this one set the stage for
that Stoke that drama fire yeah oh my
God Zach Levi what are you doing I'm
gonna twist your words today exactly if
I want to twist all your words leave a
like if you hate Zachary Levi or also
leave a like if you agree with Zachary
there's always a reason to leave a like
always ladies and gentlemen Zachary Levi
I think had good intentions but kind of
stirred more about the Flames that's the
tune of this entire conversation let's
hear it all right so this is a few days
old but it is one of those things that
has weirdly been on my mind a lot of
times like news stories they might just
come and go my brain I don't really
reflect on them this is something that
hasn't left my Noggin so I know while
we're like the last people in the world
to talk about this I feel like this kind
of has some perhaps indicators for what
the future of the DC Universe might
ultimately unfold to look like it's a
very fascinating discussion to be had
because I feel like the Divide is more
present than ever with DC fans and it
might be one of the best things for them
at this current moment before all these
announcements start coming in and I'll
go into that a little bit later as to
why quickly this this paraphrase
exactly by essentially talked about you
guys might have already heard everything
he had to say he had like a 15-minute
Instagram video and there's probably
around like two minutes of it that's
been going around where he's just sort
of rambling on his whole tone is just
basically guys it's okay look listen he
just gotta have faith in James Gunn and
Peter saffron it's like they know what
they're doing don't worry other people
didn't really like it because we could
get as much Marvel audience there's more
there's more audience to get and some
people weren't happy with previous
others were but if you weren't was more
to game that's honestly like this is
like two minutes of quotes but that's
the main takeaway that all you really
need to have from it is that and I
really believe he has good intentions
and and for the most part I actually uh
agree with what he's saying here a lot
of people are taking things and then are
just blatantly wrong and then running
them as if they're confirmed reports and
stuff and how he's had things you know
taken out of context at a set of
conventions like how he's a Snyder cut
denier this is uh
outside point of view is a man who has
never met I'm saying the word seems
Seems like a guy who's never really
quite been on board for the Snyder first
no I have never struck me as the kind of
guy who is I could be wrong I don't know
the guy it just seems that way get that
gritty brooding Shazam but he does you
know talk about how he thinks that the
next Shazam is going to be a good movie
but he did specify that he has not had
any conversations about getting the boot
from being Shazam which is interesting
because a lot of other actors have so
far and guess what camp they're all part
of it they're all part of the side
reverse camps someone's going around
behind the scenes of DC making people
sign and post of loyalty to either James
Gunn or Zack Snyder if you sign the
Snyder you're out and you know as people
who've talked about said Ezra Miller
here on the channel before I am
generally part of that camp it's like
it's kind of weird how like oh Gala does
gone Black Adam he's gone maybe if he
didn't have that same Superman at the
end he'd still be around but he's got
Ben Affleck obviously out Aquaman's
looking to be gone too it seems like
they really are adamant on the main
divide seems to be happening with the
Snyder verse so we kind of just need to
get to the point where we rip the
Band-Aid off we have the official
breakup with the Snyder verse we make
that Crystal cut clear and then we can
move on to something new that's what I
was implying earlier by how the Divide
now why make sense why some of this
stuff is coming out while they're even
allowing some of this to come out right
now before a new announcements come in
because that allows us to deal with the
breakup at the moment you know before we
move on to a new relationship with the
DC Universe as far as Ezra Miller is
concerned though I get the impression
that there's already decisions made but
they're really keeping that
they're all gonna come out after the
release of The Flash I think they're
waiting till after that but I have a
strong feeling most of that has already
been dealt with and they have a decision
of what they want to do moving forward
and that's why we're just not hearing
Jack about it because the movie has to
come out I'm still gonna make that money
Studio themselves can't disavow their
star before recouping the one thing
they're holding on to the same way how I
think Aquaman uh they might hold off on
announcing Jason Momoa was no longer
going to be Aquaman until after the lost
kingdom comes out if you make that a
confirmation that will lead more people
be like well there's literally no point
in watching this in the future yeah
there's no billion for this movie it is
fascinating too because you know like
Zachary Levi at the moment seems to be
in one of the safer positions and the
tone of his movie is different but I
feel like if you're gonna get to this
point where you're clearing house you
should clear the house you can have one
most fair thing to do dangling random as
much as I would be happy to see Shazam
continue and Zachary Levi keep on
playing the role it does seem like an
odd remainder to be like now we're
keeping this one though how to follow
that well you know I I wonder if he's
being completely honest though you know
he goes on to give them you know
vehement amounts of Praise You know he
goes on to even praise Walter Hamada he
Praises Peter saffron Who is the the
producer of the Shazam films before they
became the CFO CEOs of of the DC
Universe right part of me wonders like I
haven't had a conversation yet time to
kiss the Matrix
seriously you can't help but Wonder are
they doing that I mean it didn't really
bow well for Henry Cavill when he said
he was looking forward to having
conversations with James come but he
went on a rant he's clearly vexed by
some of the things that he has been
seeing and receiving his way you know
for for all this and it makes me wonder
you know with Peter saffron and kind of
the the DC films he produces and the
fact that they haven't had any
conversations with him if in in fact
that they would want Shazam which is the
most akin to an MCU movie out of them
all to have the DC Universe have its
heart and tone more reflect that of the
shazam movie that could work I just feel
like that would have still upset a lot
of people if that was like the course
notes you know like you would have to
introduce that idea I feel like later
after already reintroducing some new DC
stuff just to let us know what the
flavor of that is gonna be because I
feel like the main concern is what's
Batman's flavor gonna be like what's
Superman's flavor gonna be like are
those things gonna feel like the MCU
because I don't think everybody wants
that and it does make me very curious
about the who is timing all this and why
because I think your point is really apt
that he could just be damage controlling
for himself and just trying to take
advantage of the radio silence to put
his piece out there but at the same time
there are probably so many people
running around with their hair on fire
Warners too being like we need to calm
the people yeah we need to keep the
Wrath at Bay some of that tone you're
you're referencing earlier so like hey
come on guys it's fine come on some of
that speaks to me of I think he just
wants to keep his his job I would be
happy to see Shazam keep going but I
feel like it would almost tick people
off more if that became the thing where
they're like no this is the DCU movie
the DCU moving forward and this is our
Flagship character or something like
that and it's not our all if people it's
much easier to ask people to not it's
like don't think about the elephant yeah
you're going to when stuff is coming out
and stuff certain things are being
confirmed and reported then you're like
what does that mean for this what does
that mean for that what does that mean
for this one's I mean like our minds are
going to Trail and we are going to have
this discussion so you can't ask us not
to theorize about certain things you
know every part that moves affects all
the other parts and is a whole new
conversation starter I get uh asking for
don't declare that this is indeed the
truth if we don't know for sure but you
know if I think it there's no real harm
in theorizing about what might be going
on to me it sounds exactly if I really
wants to make sure he's got a job I like
him though I've listened to like much
energy to the guy I think he's a great
personality and at the end of the day I
don't disagree with a lot of what he's
saying because yeah I mean the DC's
constantly seems like it's been a divide
for such a long time even for the
projects I've Loved I know like there's
another camera
but yeah guys leave your thoughts down
below do you agree with Zach Levi or not
what do you think his statements will
ultimately mean leave your thoughts down
below subscribe leave a like click that
Bell last one on Lisa sent us with a
Brian John shot Brian Perry Brian Perry
Shazam I just feel so filled with joy
like a bolt of lightning from the sky
when I read your name it's spelled
interestingly but it's also like Snappy
it sounds like a like a person you'd
want to sing you a song Maybe or
somebody that you would listen to like
Sage wise advice from Brian Perry I hope
you are having a nice holiday season
whichever holiday you celebrate I don't
make any assumptions here you had a bad
day today well here we're here to make
it better Brian
you know life it doesn't always give you
what you want Brian but the important
thing is is that you're still showing up
every day and uh you're still showing up
at this patreon paid sleeping and
haphazard yeah keep keep on sleeping and
just never waking up to unpledge
yourself from your family situation and
then yeah just wake up in like you know
20 30 odd years you've got this like you
know Timeless huge beard and you don't
even know where you are and that this
that patreon keeps suffering from
dehydration now to you crawl to the near
River if you can if your body doesn't
give out in uh you know in in uh yeah
it's it's real tough out there in these
in these sleeping for 30 years streets
so uh thanks for being part of our
patreon thanks Brian Perry
[Music]